good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2137
object class thaumiel previously euclid
and ketter special containment
procedures
when not being used scp-2137 is to be
kept within a typical electronic
10-digit metal safe
in the safe wing of site-23 all digital
and wireless broadcast media
must be kept at least 100 meters away
from scp-2137
due to scp-2137's anomalous effect
having been determined to have no ranged
limit
digital wireless and broadcast media may
be used but should be monitored closely
for any appearance of scp-2137-1
or 2. other than testing and recording
of track 7
scp-2137 should be considered an
inanimate item without agency of its own
and any demands or threats made by
scp-2137-2
should be ignored once a week scp-2137
is to be cleaned and all tracks are to
be played in succession with special
attention paid to the instance of
scp-2137-1
that replaces track 7. the names
situations and anecdotes presented in
that instance of scp-2137-1
must then be reported to 2137 special
committee
pockwatch on the rare occasion that
non-foundation organizations cannot
address the situation presented in an
instance of scp-21371
o59 has given authorization to activate
mobile task force 33.9
to take any and all measures necessary
to reach a resolution
to the problem operational success will
be indicated
by a new instance of 1.
personnel who wish to examine or attempt
to interact with scp-2137
must ask dr kivowitz for authorization
beforehand
which will then pend o5 clearance
description scp-2137
is a single compact disc copy of me
against the world a hip-hop album by the
artist tupac shakur
released in 1995. physical examination
as well as laser testing indicates that
the cd was one of the initial release
manufactured and distributed in 1995.
conventional testing of the disk itself
reveals identical results to a
non-anomalous copy of the album
the case and liner notes have been
determined to have no anomalous
qualities
and the physical makeup and encoding of
the disc appear completely normal
however upon playing track 7 normally
heavy in the game the listener will
encounter an instance of scp-2137-1
the anomaly takes the form of
spontaneously generated
professionally produced songs featuring
tupac shakur
in various styles within the hip-hop
genre
though each instance of scp-2137-1
generated is unique
they share certain commonalities in
terms of subject matter
the central focus of the song invariably
addresses a crime almost always a murder
or series of murders and then gives
necessary anecdotal evidence or
information
to correctly identify and prosecute the
killer
even going so far as to specify
prosecutors
or recommend vigilante justice
though generation of scp-21371 has been
determined to have a definite causal
nature
the manner in which scp-2137-1 instances
are copied
onto scp-2137 has yet to be ascertained
scp-2137-2
the primary voice on the songs from
herein identifying as
scp-2137 matches cleanly through
advanced audio analysis to that of the
real tupac shakur
who died in 1996 over a year before the
recovery of scp-2137
however occasionally on crimes of a
particularly complicated or brutal
nature
scp-2137-2 will be joined by other
performers
either guest rapping or singing the
chorus or
bridge this has included many of tupac's
contemporaries
such as snoop doggy dog noss no doubt
everclear weezer and buster rhymes
as well as artists from the 2000s
including chris brown
katy perry lil wayne lady gaga
rihanna the yin yang twins drake
neon trees jet jay z kanye west
and eminem usually at the height of
their popularity
on a few notable occasions involving
long unsolved crimes by still active
criminals
there have been guests of a more
blatantly anachronistic nature
standouts among whom include phil harris
the
andrews sisters frank sinatra buddy
holly
the who elvis presley diana ross
and the beatles heavily anachronistic
guests tend to take the role of primary
artist
the song performed in their style with
scp-2137
joining as a rap guest when contacted
none of these artists had any
recollection of recording for or
information regarding scp-2137
the crimes themselves share that they
are unsolved or
in some cases have escaped detection
entirely
the majority of instances of scp-21371
address crimes of private citizens such
as serial killers
spree murderers or career criminals
though
occasionally the songs will address
larger groups such as hamas
isis the ira and even in two separate
instances
the chaos insurgency and the church of
the broken god
a prototypical example of scp-21371
is included here for reference this is
an excerpt from scp-2137-1
log 542.
now i gotta be doing detective work
at the hardest time huh
jeffrey gert still stalking tonight
killed his brother and some strangers
with the same damn night
right it's none of my plans to tell you
what to do i knew what i would do if i
was you if i was you
he hit the blade in the barn off north
111 he already killed six don't make it
seven
don't make it be careful and play it
smart
when the crimes have been addressed and
the guilty parties brought to light
either by the legal system or otherwise
scp-2137-1 1
is immediately replaced by a new
instance
however the track is easily recorded
through conventional means
recorded versions are not subject to
change or replacement
and the original can be replayed from
the cd endlessly before the killer is
found with
no or little variation there are
currently nearly 1 000
instances of scp-21371 on record
initial recovery log scp-213
was recovered in the home of avon
lincoln arrested for the vigilante
slaying of michael ferris
who was later revealed to have been the
ogi strangler
responsible for six murders over the
summer of 1996.
avon's insistence that tupac shakur
spoke to him from beyond the grave
and told him he had to take justice into
his own hands because ferris's position
as district attorney would prevent a
fair trial
drew the attention of foundation agents
after the song in question was produced
as evidence in court
amnestics were administered to all
involved and lincoln was released back
into the general population
addendum 1a the xk incident
initially researchers experimented with
anonymously tipping off local police
departments through foundation plants
which led to the resolution of over cold
cases
including the recovery of scp scp
and scp-617 though no direct link has
been established
other than the murders involved however
after years this use of the scp was
deemed
impractical repeatedly addressing the
crimes discussed in 2137's music was
in practice allowing the scp to dictate
the circumstances of its containment
and under the wrong circumstances opened
the foundation to potential exposure
through continuous interaction with law
enforcement
at all levels across multiple
governments
in response to this 059 ceased
addressing the crimes
in late 2000 after two months passed
scp-2130 behavior radically
changed when for the first time an
instance of scp-21371 was produced
that revealed scp-2137-2 had an
awareness of its containment
this is an excerpt from scp-2137-1
log 851
you said you all about security but you
not good guys
you reject and expunge man your silence
is lost you said you here to protect but
the killers weren't free don't let me
show you how rough this outlaw can be
you couldn't stop the beast so don't you
start that struggle you better watch
your tone
unless you looking for trouble man you
need to fall back and let me do my duty
locked in the drawer feeling like you're
trying to screw me you try to step up on
my legacy
you don't believe that i'm tupac i'm not
just a cd
the decision was made to halt testing
entirely
rather than acquiesce after one week
passed
an instance of scp-21371 appeared
spontaneously
on the youtube channel of los
angeles-based hip-hop station
and in the lone hour before it was taken
down accrued over
views xk scenario incident
the image displaying on the video was a
still photograph
apparently authentic though its nature
is highly anomalous
the photograph is of shakur estimated to
be in his early 40s
it would be wise to note at the time of
his murder in 1996
shikora was 25 years old wearing the
garb of foundation d-class personnel
with his middle fingers raised the
accompanying song titled
focused on scp revealing its actual
location
and means by which it could be broken
free of current containment procedures
and identified several members of the o5
council
by their first names as it described the
function
and nature of the foundation in a
massive sweeping operation involving
activation of multiple task forces
across
continents all trace of the video was
erased and all
viewers were administered class a
amnestics midway through this operation
an entire album titled case scenario was
released to the itunes account of
beyonce knowles
each song featured scp-2137-2 as well as
a variety of guest artists
and focused on a different ketter class
scp currently
in captivity though scp tracking bots
were able to bring
x-case scenario down only after
downloads
complete digital eradication of the
individual files
has proven difficult though no loss of
life or property was incurred
the sheer scale of the danger posed by
this containment breach
prompted a foundation-wide state of high
alert
this prompted an ongoing upgrade to all
automatic scp firewalls
and engendered the reclassification of
scp-2137
from euclid to ketter the breach
sparked heated debate as to how to
proceed with the containment of
and conceptual understanding regarding
scp-2137
which came to an end upon the appearance
of a new instance of scp-21371
this instance was produced spontaneously
through the mouth of scp
which appeared to fall into a trance
state during the incident
with the lyrics in totality repeatedly
written in what was identified as
117 000 times all over the interior of
its containment chamber
this is an excerpt from scp-2137-1
log 564.
here
and if you think about a plan imma [ __ ]
[ __ ] up you try to hide it but i see it
all
now i'm coming for your head like i'm
telling off you don't want to fall
dressed in black like you can't be seen
i brought alone i don't need no t
so do your job
the decision was made to resume the
former method of testing
involving the embedded informants used
to relay scp-2137's evidence
and information while continuing to
study the method in which
scp-2137 transmits its broadcasts in an
effort to truly contain it completely
scp-2137-2 resumed its previous
behavioral pattern
scp-2137-1s focusing on crimes
until their killers are located by
conventional law enforcement
with the exception of one final track at
this time
its last recorded direct interaction
with the foundation
this is an excerpt from scp-2137-1
log 565.
see i knew y'all get
listen y'all can't afford
y'all cannot afford to lose and y'all
will lose going against me
so it's only right it's only right
but now that we on the same page
that's what i got for y'all i guess it
took time for it to sink in
i'm just glad you understood what i was
thinking i just knew you come around so
you see it now
it ain't no need to get upset or even
throw down you know i got the crown
i see it's hard to get some sleep at
night you got a head full of grades and
your skin ain't tight
huh so let's be real and ain't no need
to fight it there's a grain of design i
bet you're gonna like it
it's black and white so don't get caught
up in the deep thoughts you got my music
on the side with a greater force
you got my music on the side with the
greater force
investigation into any kind of link or
pattern between the crimes scp-2137
solves is
ongoing as is interest to why it doesn't
use its agency to pursue the criminals
in question
rather than working through proxies
memorandum email from site 515 director
dr gwen
pristine 205 council regarding tupac
this will be the fifth time i have
written to propose an update to scp-2371
when they enter our program here at site
515
researchers engineers mtf troops and
even d-class all walk in the door having
read the official documentation
and believe the foundation has been
essentially blackmailed into cooperation
with the devious
scp but everyone who actually works here
know this is no longer the case
in the nearly three decades since
containment the foundation's
collaboration with scp-212
has led to recovery of dozens of scps
our mobile task forces have deposed
dictators and topple tyrants
chased down rogue reality vendors from
three portlands to lamplight
this of course all adjacent to the
arrest or end of nearly 30
000 murders to add some perspective here
a serial killer hasn't made it past
their third victim anywhere on earth in
14 years
scp-2137 has produced over forty
thousand unique pieces of music
function at site five one five has
become effectively frictionless
first it was just the suge knights but
as we became more effective at
addressing scp-2137
instruction another mtf joined then an
elite division
which brings us up to the present where
the five mobile task forces under my
command are in constant action against
forces
all over the planet earth and beyond all
under the guidance of detailed strategy
provided by the mysterious music from a
compact disc that the foundation has
failed to adequately contain
a silent undocumented understanding has
grown among us
the scp does not simply catch murderers
it directly and aggressively searches
out anything that maliciously
takes a human life the amount of lives
saved and untold disasters that have
been prevented through the information
two one three seven supplies are at this
point stupefying to contemplate
much less that it has been able to
essentially bully us into a pattern of
unilaterally heroic expenditures of
foundation resources
it's little wonder that we show the
highest numbers globally in foundation
morale test
it makes sense of course here at site
515 the
scp foundation is a fast action team of
gun slinging heroes
smashing cults blowing away terrorists
and catching murders and monsters in our
spare time as we blast rap music out of
a landing attack hovercraft
or working behind the scenes turning
local cops into super sleuths and
vigilantes into heroes
but this period as productive as it's
been has been intellectually stagnant
throughout all of this the motives and
origin of 2137 remain a mystery
defying every search for a pattern every
algorithm-driven analysis
the research wing of the site has become
a ghost town as the mtf response
barracks have grown to dominate
everything and perhaps
rightfully so but a few young
researchers have diligently continued to
hunt for meaning
for greater truth behind scp-21371
an unexpected advance in this area is
behind the urgency in my message to you
today
it had long been understood that the
life of the actual tupac shakur held
little information or relevance toward
the mystery of scp-2137's existence this
has potentially changed researcher
marija
kozlovich recently came across an
unreleased interview with secure from
1994
two years before his death and three
before the discovery of scp-213
the interview was buried by his managers
because there was anxiety about shakur's
mental state in the footage
because he was speaking what they called
nonsense
i think you will agree that while mr
shakur may not have been speaking
clearly
what he actually says is very possibly a
vital interest to the foundation
and very definitely not nonsense i feel
we may finally have
if not an answer at the beginnings of
one but i can say with certainty that in
my entire time at the foundation i have
never
personally felt this excited
so i start my proposal here a ketter
level object
actively interested in aiding the human
race is not a ketter level object at all
i am officially resubmitting my proposal
for scp-2137 to at long last be
redesignated a thumbnail class object
and for a quadrupling of our research
team in a site resource allocation
we must tug this thread and see where it
leads us perhaps after hearing the audio
attached
you will finally agree dr gwen pristine
site director 515
document recovered footage 1l
tupac shakur dressed casually sits on a
large red couch
smoking a marijuana cigarette hunched
forward and visibly intoxicated
with drooping eyes and slightly slurred
speech
he seems happy and jovial and laughs
often through the interview despite
repeatedly becoming distracted by the
presence of his entourage dancing
and talking in the room his director and
videographer gobi rahimi sits nearby
and vh1 interviewer mila vendi also
visibly intoxicated
sits nearby the relevant portion begins
9 minutes and 14 seconds
into the interview
people ask me where i get my inspiration
from
they say how do you go so hard and put
in that much work
but what they don't understand is
this is me taking a break this is me
on vacation i think some people will say
that was irresponsible
to just sit back be human for a while be
an
artist experience that i can't be
chasing the king all the time
i feel like i've been doing that forever
to protect you holly you
he's not so big you're not so small
but but but but he's got to trick you
like it doesn't matter because that's
the only way that he can keep it looking
like he's the man
like he's some big bad evil [ __ ]
you don't see that when i die i'll live
on my death is my destiny
and then i become something else when i
was before
the voice would still shout and it shout
justice
and poetry and art and music
i got you i got you humanity
when i eventually go toe-to-toe and
brawl with this fool
he's gonna gather up his little red
dress and go home crying like a [ __ ]
and he knows it evil knows his days are
numbered
so the king is still running the chase
isn't over
prepare prepare
prepare
you know working for a foundation such
as this
it's kind of heartwarming to see that
not every anomalous entity out there
is malevolent for once a thousand class
object that can't be contained
is kind of a good thing maybe most
people
disagree with me who knows
anyway i think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
it's not a spoon corey barker
arbiter soul retalias
karim el ashmoy seven past midnight
matthew gilmore fana matakik
eric corbidge kawaii fire keeper
joker corvus king madding
bryson samurai corgis
james saba nj vujak
and justin day if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you